the u.s now averages more than 69
000 new coronavirus cases a day
that's an all-time high and 12 000
americans have been hospitalized for
kovid
over the last month a jump of nearly 40
percent
this morning we hear from three doctors
who say hospitals
are close to their breaking point our
lead national correspondent david begnow
has our report
the situation in utah's hospitals is
increasingly dire
experts are warning that doctors may
soon need to confront the unthinkable
rationing health care as beds fill up
and staff
are stretched then dr eddie stinium is
an infectious disease physician there
at this point there's really no end in
sight for us our case counts are
continue to rise
our hospitalizations are continuing to
rise so there's no rounding the curve
for us here in utah
the possibility of having to ration care
is also becoming a concern in parts of
idaho
where covet hospitalizations have more
than doubled since the beginning of
october
at saint luke's magic valley dr joshua
kern
says roughly 30 percent of the
hospital's 150 patients
are infected with coronavirus it's
totally unprecedented
even during bad influenza seasons it's
not like we see
you know a third of the patients in the
hospital with influenza
teetering on the brink right we're right
there we need to turn things around or
we're going to be in big trouble
to wisconsin now dr jeff pothoff at
university hospital in madison
says four of his hospital's coveted
wings are full
so they're opening another converted
wing this week
it's never been worse for us here in
wisconsin and every day it's not getting
better
it's getting a little bit worse the ice
is so thin right now as we try to do
everything we can get as creative as we
can to take care of all the patients
that need our services
all three of these doctors agree there
is no end in sight
for the pandemic for cbs this morning
i'm david begno
in new york so it continues